I'm seriously pissed about the story is
getting completely swept under the rug
between all this Isis stuff and then the
Ray Rice thing so President Obama
announced this week that he's gonna push
his decision on immigration to after the
elections in November now why would he
do that now okay so just real quick we
know the Republican suck I say it every
week they suck they're not helping
they're not trying to make compromise
they're not trying to do anything that
so he can't get legislation passed that
he can sign to make immigration reform
at the same time uh he knows that it
will be unpopular for him to do any
executive action now so he's announcing
that he's gonna wait to do something
unpopular till after the election to
help the Democrats so this just reeks of
everything that sucks about politics all
around bad Republicans then using an
executive action which is sort of a
betrayal the separation of powers it's a
lot it's a lot of [ __ ] it's just sort of
what drives me nuts about politics in
general uh but let's look at the White
House official statement on what the
president's gonna do the reality the
President had to weigh is that were in
the midst of the political season and
because of the Republicans extreme
politicization of the issue the
President believes it would be harmful
to the policy itself into the long-term
prospects for comprehensive immigration
reform to announce administration action
before the election so you really need
to think about what he's saying there
he's gonna do something that's
politically unpopular that his base
wanting to do right now so the
progressives all the people left want
him to do immigration reform right now
but he's doesn't have the balls to do it
right now cuz he thinks it's gonna hurt
the Democrats the Republicans are
playing ball it's just everything and
I've now said ten times it's everything
sort of that sucks about politics
wrapped up in one thing uh politics just
sucks how's that how's that for a
question does politics just suck sucks I
think that's all we need to say videos
done that's it no I mean I'm not
surprised cuz this actually would hurt
the Democrats in the midterm election so
I mean I'm not surprised I mean what
politician makes political decision for
for elections yeah shocking but shooting
a president a two-term president in his
six-year almost entering lame status be
a little more brave and say I'm just
gonna [ __ ] do it like to me it's the
idea that he's even telling us they're
flat-out telling us like we're playing
politics in the worst
let me ask you do you really think I
mean are you Jen are you generally upset
genuinely upset are you just playing
devil's advocate here because I he's
just blatantly saying how it is where as
opposed to in the past a lot of
politicians have been like having a lot
of empty promises and I'm gonna do and
teetering around things he's just
flat-out saying I'm not gonna do it
because it's gonna mess us up real bad I
think I mean I have to give him some
credit in that regard of thing ok so
I'll give him that much credit I'll give
him that like you're telling us how
stupid the system is and you're being
honest about that so I'll give him that
it's like a filibuster of you know not
taking action in this larger writer I
guess what I'm more annoyed about here
is just that this that he's six years in
and they just never i know the
republicans suck i say it every week but
like they just never figured out a way
to make anything work so instead he has
to do an executive action you know we
have separation of powers so Congress is
supposed to make laws and he's supposed
to sign them but what he's saying is i'm
just gonna wait till after the elections
to do something you don't want me to do
because it's gonna hurt my guys
democrats and then I'm gonna do
something that I don't really have the
authority to do so I guess I'll give
them a little credit for the eyes and
and also also I do my concern in this is
that this is going to drive more
Republicans to the polls to assure that
they get the slots and it's gonna end up
backfiring and then he's just gonna be
expected so I totally buy that and I've
already seen this in the right wing
websites and blogs and everything
they're all like you see what he's gonna
do you see me a new so it energizes
their base so is he accidentally
strengthening the other side what's
going on here I mean maybe the whole
thing is like he said politics sucks
republicans suck democrats suck
everybody sucks i mean he is being
honest at least and telling us why he's
doing what he's doing kind of though
because he said that he would have this
done before the end of summer right oh
that's all he was breaking his own
promise yeah yeah i'll do it soon and
now he's saying he'll do it after the
elections if he even does it then maybe
he'll keep kicking the can down the road
and that's what people are mad because
he keeps just procrastinating and
delaying things you know cutemon civil
rights can wait okay
immigration reform policies to change
perfect sense immigration since we
started coming over the borders from on
the Mayflower yes I've been waiting for
immigration so yeah exactly i don't know
the thing is we've literally every
politician has used this as a platform
or a speaking point throughout their
term and it still hasn't happened but
we're just focusing on him because he's
like yeah I'm not doing it right now so
just hold up you know he said it just
like that right to my mind oh yeah isn't
it just sad though that a president six
years into it still has to be playing
politics i guess that fundamentally is
one of sad things about a lot of
presidents that we've had so so yeah
it's just kinda yeah alright final
thought on this solve immigration for me
what do you guys think cuz i think this
is also what nobody ever talks about on
the news is what do actual regular
people like if what do you basically
think about immigration what should we
be doing like basically base in 30
seconds give me what i mean it's tough
because there are a lot of people who
are doing it legally you know so you
don't want to make them feel like you
know what's the point everybody's just
you know sneaking in anyways and there
are a lot of criminal issues that come
into play with this but you have to
remember that we are a nation of
immigrants so everybody who's high and
mighty who thinks that all they need to
go back to their own country where do
you think you came from yeah we're fine
that's what they told me in third grade
yeah we should we should nourish safer
avenues for people that have been here
contributing to society for them to
become legal citizens and you know and
then we should strengthen borders and
make their there be a more streamlined
process of having legal channels i mean
it's really about making it a safer
space for people who have been here you
know to actually like move forward with
establishing citizenship here it's like
making it a safer place for them to come
out and say it because it's so taboo and
people who have been here for 20 years
still are you know tiptoeing around
around applying for healthcare applying
for different things it's like these
people are just as American as your eye
yeah I mean literally they're separating
families that have been here for 20
years and they then deport a kid who
gets pulled over for a stoplight yeah I
basically I agree with
both my esteemed guests on this one yeah
let's secure the borders let's just get
that secure if we can possibly do that
and then figure out a way for all the
people that are already here to announce
it and let's get them in and then we'll
deal with everybody else and I know
that's kind of buying this guy stuff but
I have a feeling maybe we can do it with
an executive action or some other half
cocked measures